se llegó el día en el que circulará de
forma oficial en el salvador encuentro
delante de uno de los 200 cajeros
automáticos que el gobierno ha instalado
en todo el país para que la población
pueda acceder a la cripta moneda sin
embargo la afluencia de personas ha sido
muy poca y la concurrencia más es de
parte de la prensa nacional e
internacional así como orientadores que
se encargan de dar indicaciones sobre la
instalación de la billetera electrónica
oficial chivo wallet y del uso del
cajero he logrado platicar con
transeúntes del centro capitalino y
existe mucho escepticismo pues prefieren
esperar un tiempo prudencial para ver el
funcionamiento de la cripto divisa
también hay convocadas diversas
manifestaciones en rechazo al víctor
pues consideran que es una moneda
altamente volátil que no puede funcionar
como medio de pago